deal with australia
an ambitious target from president
biden's administration for 40 of
electricity to come from solar energy by
2035.
and who should pay to make homes greener
we'll be discussing that in today's
daily debate
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
and we start today with allegations of
broken promises after sky news revealed
how ministers agreed to bow to pressure
from australia to drop binding climate
commitments from the uk australian trade
deal the chair of the climate change
committee says the uk is failing to show
leadership on the issue after a leaked
email showed how the trade secretary liz
truss and the business secretary quasi
quatting decided to drop two key targets
from the text of the agreement well
among the areas to be removed was a
reference to the paris agreement
temperature goals now back at cop21 in
paris in 2015 countries agreed to work
towards limiting global warming to 2
degrees preferably 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels and you can see
here on our data dashboard how we're
already at more than 1.2 degrees of
warming that number going up the whole
time
well our deputy political editor sam
coates broke that story here's his full
report
good morning
the australian prime minister in downing
street just three months ago to seal
with a bump of the elbow
the uk's first big trade deal done from
scratch with australia
tim tams penguins plenty of banter they
agreed the principles of the deal and
what seemed to be a shared approach on
the environment we talked about climate
change and uh the shared ambition we
have to have a fantastic cop
26 summit in november to reduce
global emissions
but sky news can reveal that weeks later
the trade secretary and the business
secretary gave into a new australian
demand
a leaked email seen by sky said that the
business secretary has agreed that in
order to get the australia fta free
trade agreement over the line the dit
department for international trade can
drop both of the climate asks including
a reference to the paris agreement
temperature goals
one of the conservatives most senior
environmentalists who chairs the
committee advising government on climate
was scathing
if we're not prepared to hang our hat
on the
paris agreement to which we have put our
solemn promise and which we have put by
law into action in this country when
we're dealing with australia which is
one of the recalcitrant nations one of
the countries that's not doing what it
ought to do then really we are not
taking the lead at all and to do this at
a time before cop 26 is very serious
[Music]
the government insists that the
forthcoming australia trade deal will
uphold the paris climate change
agreement
but australia made these demands for a
reason and it's significant that
ministers went along with them in secret
climate change is all about upholding
commitment once the spotlight has moved
on rather than doing anything to help
skeptical nations get out of their
obligations
the australian skepticism comes despite
wildfires that have ripped across the
country in recent years
but a senior australian politician made
clear why dropping temperature targets
was their red line i welcome the fact
that uh the uk is recognizing that we
are no longer a colony
of the united kingdom
the uk does not get to decide what
policies are put in place here in
australia keep in mind the paris
agreement's non-vital
it's not law it did not go through the
u.s senate was not considered a treaty
it's an aspirational agreement that a
bunch of countries signed up to
green groups saw this coming in the uk
australia trade deal pleading in a
letter to the prime minister earlier
this year saying it is not worth the
rush to do a deal if the outcome causes
significant damage to the planet
last month the prime minister responded
saying that the deal commits both
parties to collaborate on climate and
environmental issues he said we are
clear more trade will not come at the
expense of the environment
that promise has been broken says the
head of greenpeace the reason why he
wrote this letter was because he was
basically saying trade and the
environment cannot be separated he said
this is not going to be a race to the
bottom what this email shows is that
that is just a bare-faced lie that
actually what they're doing is the
opposite this is a race to the bottom
and it is a disaster if the government
is giving in on these environmental
regulations it is truly shocking and it
is truly seismic in terms of the impact
that that will have
ministers still want a thumbs up on the
deal within weeks australia is prepared
to wait if needs be that means
compromises some might not like
and sam joins me from westminster now so
sam what are the implications of this
for the uk government as hosts of cop 26
at the climate summit
well this is partly about britain's
leverage over australia as we head into
the clock cop climate change
summit the backdrop with australia uh is
worrying according to environmentalists
it was just this week yesterday in fact
that we had a statement from the
resources minister in australia saying
that coal was going to play a big part
of that country's energy supply well
into the 2030s they're going
head-to-head with the un that's trying
to persuade australia to reduce its coal
consumption one of the reasons it's
reluctant to have targets like the ones
that have now been removed from the uk
australia trade deal
in internationally binding agreements
but i think as you say the greater
significance is for uk ministers ahead
of cop the optics of taking out part of
a binding agreement in secret that many
environmentalists thought had been
committed to by the british prime
minister is not a good look as here we
are 51 days to go until that climate
change summit begins climate change
commitments are all um
are made at summit but they have to be
upheld over long periods when the
spotlight isn't necessarily quite as
focused on you and i think it's this
idea that commitments are being whittled
away and watered down in private
that could send a signal around the
world
of a way that britain operates it's the
worst kind of
signal that you can send at this point
and i think that's why today's story is
so potentially damaging even though
government officials are trying to play
down its significance
sam thanks very much indeed
and a reminder that you can read more
about this and all the other climate
stories of the day on our website just
head to
skynews.com climate
in today's other climate news a scheme
offering home owners grants to reduce
their energy bills racked up 50 million
pounds in administration costs a
watchdog has found now that's the
equivalent of one thousand pounds for
each household that took part under the
green homes grant scheme homeowners
could claim vouchers from the government
to cover the cost of energy saving
improvements such as double glazing or
roof insulation the scheme was abandoned
in march after reports of applicants not
being reimbursed for construction
and we're going to be discussing how we
can make our homes climate friendly and
who should pay for it in today's daily
climate show debate i'm going to be
joined by seppi golzari munro from the
energy and climate intelligence unit and
extinction rebellion activist chidi oti
obihara and that's coming up in a few
minutes time
the president of this year's cop 26
summit says he's had constructive talks
with china about their contribution to
climate change after several days of
discussions alok sharma said time is
running out to prevent a climate
catastrophe adding that the choices
china makes on energy shape our shared
future
and critically endangered european eels
can now access feeding grounds in a uk
river before heading back to the
atlantic to breed thanks to a new eel
pass
the eels start their life off the coast
of the u.s before migrating to europe
but the number making the journey has
fallen by around 95
in the last 40 years due to habitat loss
and climate change the new pass lifts
the fish above obstructions to the river
hull allowing them to continue their
journey
to the united states now where president
biden's administration has released a
report claiming that the country will
get 40 percent of its electricity from
solar energy by
2035. well our correspondent and smith
is in washington for us so helena tell
us more about this announcement then
well the report uh anna lays out how uh
what could happen what how much uh solar
energy could be used to try and
decarbonize the national grid here in
america this is certainly what president
biden would want to see and numbers are
pretty stark as you said there 40
percent of the u.s energy could be
provided by solar by 2035 that would be
enough to power every single residential
home and in the meantime as well that
could create 1.5 million jobs the
administration says now the look to
solar perhaps not a surprise it's by far
the cheapest renewable energy source
it's some of the fastest growing as well
and there's been a number of recent
climate catastrophes here in america
that not only highlight the need to act
quickly but have also highlighted some
of the weaknesses in the energy grid
here in america hurricane ida for
example just last week left thousands
louisiana without electricity for a long
period of time
and of course remember as well president
biden is the president who wants to be
seen to take action on climate change
but of course big targets ambitious
plans come with big challenges as well
at the moment only three percent of the
us energy is provided by solar so that
amount would need to be quadrupled in
terms of the capacity added every year
so a huge challenge and then of course
the plan is quite broad at the moment in
this report there needs to be specifics
and those specifics need to make it
through congress and here in america
where things like climate policy can be
very politicized that's not necessarily
an easy or a guaranteed thing
hello nan thanks very much indeed
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by sepi
gazari monroe acting director of the
energy and climate intelligence unit and
chidi oti obihara co-founder of the cop
26 climate action plan they're standing
by already welcome to both of you we'll
be talking to them in just a moment
discussing that exclusive story about
climate targets being dropped from the
uk australia trade deal plus how can we
make our homes more climate friendly do
join us next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to philip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
air pollution levels will improve over
the next few days as the weather turns
more unsettled and breezy heavy and
thundery downpours will break out just
about anywhere on thursday and it will
still feel rather humid there will be
some brighter spells between the showers
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high predominantly low levels of
air pollution are expected on thursday
as the weather turns more unsettled
cooler and breezy
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now as well as
challenging the solutions to them with
sepi golzari monroe acting director of
the energy and climate intelligence unit
and chidi oti obihara an extinction
rebellion activist and co-founder of the
cop 26 climate action plan so good
evening to both of you really good to
see though
earlier in the program we heard how sky
news has learned that the uk government
agreed to drop binding climate
commitments from the uk australian trade
deal now amongst the areas to be removed
was a reference to paris agreement
temperature goals that aim to keep
global warming to two degrees preferably
1.5 degrees above pre-industrial levels
so should we sacrifice climate
leadership for economic gain let's
discuss this now step to you first of
all how much do you think this matters i
mean a trade deal with australia is in
uk's economic interest isn't it do we
have to accept sometimes that
compromises might have to be made for
the sake of trade and prosperity
um i mean i think the first thing to say
here anna is that the notion that action
on climate change in the environment is
somehow at odds with prosperity is very
outdated it simply doesn't reflect
market and social dynamics in the 21st
century in the uk alone we've reduced
emissions by roughly 42 while growing
the economy by 78
so the argument simply doesn't stand um
but with reference to the this uh this
leak regarding the trade deal if true
um
it would be a politically baffling move
really i mean concern about climate
change in the environment has never been
higher brits now rate environment and
climate is the second most important
issue facing the country second only to
the covert 19 pandemic so it's not clear
to me whether this is a really a vote
winner
well it's interesting isn't it the
government certainly is playing it down
let's take a look at some of what
they've said in response to this story
they say our ambitious trade deal with
australia will include a substantive
article on climate change in fact
they say that this is a first it's the
first time australia will have ever
included climate provisions in a trade
deal even if those specific temperature
targets aren't included so so what do
you make of that response
well i think the response is is a way of
trying to ameliorate fairly complicated
issues one of them is the fact that
australia measures its own climate
progress in different ways
so they've talked about
going from 26 to 28
decreases in their emissions compared to
a 2005 levels whereas the uk uh talks
about reducing by 68
uh from 1990 levels to 20 30 levels now
there's a lot of complicated mathematics
that goes on within this but nothing
hides the fact that australia houses
79 out of the 176
new coal-fired power stations that are
being set up globally
australia is trying to get out of its
own paris agreement commitments by not
committing appropriately to the paris
government commitments the uk has within
this uh a free trade agreement and
that's wrong the uk should be setting an
example not following laggards
well um seppi i think australian
ministers would say they are committed
to the paris agreement but they may
argue we have got a lot of jobs in the
coal industry and if you're a uk trade
negotiator what are you supposed to do
if you come up against that argument are
you supposed to abandon the trade deal
what would you do
i'd say anna honestly the question is
not which jobs we lose by going net zero
by addressing the paris climate
agreement it's actually which jobs we
lose out on if we don't and there's no
denying that there are jobs in carbon
intensive industries but there are plans
and there will be plans developed to
help retrain and transition uh those
people and i think you know the key
thing to remember here is the world is
moving on already at least two-thirds of
global global gdp is covered by net zero
targets and many businesses are already
getting ahead of this curve and setting
themselves earlier targets bringing jobs
in the process i mean in the uk alone
you know over the summer we saw you know
six thousand jobs for battery tech in
coventry another six thousand two
hundred battery tech in sunderland
another one thousand in eevee production
in cheshire and that's just the tip of
the iceberg and you know we can see
actually net zero breathing life into
britain's former industrial heartlands
and um it's it's really a case of
actually you know seeing the opportunity
here seeing that businesses are
innovating and bringing jobs but
recognizing that there are those that
are affected that needs to be um you
know helped and supported to retrain and
transition on the risk of missing the
point of what's being discussed here
because it's really really important to
focus on the fact that australia is a
nation that hasn't been able to meet um
some of the most obvious uh targets for
for cutting emissions some of the most
obvious projects such as stopping uh
issues like the adani mine project one
that's so big that it's visible a coal
mine so big it's visible from space if
the uk is going to have trade agreements
with countries like australia the uk
can't spend time placating them the uk
has to actually set an example that
others follow this is the year of cop
and britain is after all britain i know
that we've come out of the eu and we
thought we were going to be able to
solve some problems the common
agricultural policy but it's a really
big missed opportunity if we try and get
trade agreements that are set up with no
reference to paris temperature goals i
think that's unacceptable okay let's
move on to the other subject we wanted
to talk about which is that it's been
revealed today that the government's
green homes grant scheme cost a thousand
pounds for each household that took part
just an administration now the
initiative was scrapped in march after
facing problems with delivery but making
our homes more climate friendly is going
to be key if the uk is going to meet its
climate target so how can we make our
homes greener and who should pay for it
actually to you first of all it was a
pretty damning assessment by the
national audit office about the green
homes grant so looking to the future how
do we go about making our homes more
energy efficient
well what we need is a properly
administered government program so that
we get a just transition in the process
there are no routes out of energy
poverty that don't include renewable
energy so when the national audit office
says that the 12-week timetable that the
hm uh treasury department set for this
entire program for 600 000 homes in the
middle of covet last year when they say
it was overambitious the national audit
are actually being incredibly diplomatic
what basically happened was a
really good very important scheme that
would they delivered you know hundreds
of thousands of jobs and saved hundreds
of uh thousands of tons of co2
fell apart because the way it was
administered and the period during which
it was administered just didn't allow it
to be effective
we need to do what the ippr suggests
which is go back
focus on local delivery focus on local
people focus on job creation and carry
out the the the green homes grant that
62 percent of the public were about to
apply for until it was cut prematurely
okay stephanie i just want to to explain
why we're talking about this why it's
important because there is a statistic
here from the national uh housing
federation that shows that england's
homes produce more carbon emissions
every year than all of the country's
cars which is an extraordinary
stat isn't it but it's expensive isn't
it i mean if you're going to insulate
people's home put double glazing in
you're going to take out people's gas
boilers it all costs money so who pays
for that is it the individuals do we pay
through the tax system how should we pay
i mean you raise the really important
points and the reason this is all being
discussed is there's actually a vacuum
at the moment whereby you know we're
waiting for a heat and building strategy
to come from the uk government uh we
were anticipating that before the summer
it's uh it's now looking like it's
coming uh in before october and that is
um you know critical and not only in
setting a date for phasing out
gas brothers but but also actually
setting out some policies that can
actually help support people
apologies for cutting you off sepi we're
out of time but we'll discuss this
another time i promise but uh sepia and
chidi thanks so much for joining us here
tonight and that's everything from us
for today joining me on the show
tomorrow will be economist and former
joint head of the uk's government
economic service vicky price and the
independence climate columnist donica
mccarthy
do stay tuned coming up next on sky news
tonight tory mps are expected to approve
the highest tax rise for decades
breaking one manifesto promise on tax to
pay for another